what's the probability that Hans cheated
over the board against Magnus in the in
St Louis that's a tough one man
have you even allowed yourself to to put
a probability on it no not on that
specific game because I think a lot of
that game was affected by magnus's own
psyche that was one of his worst games
ever so he played poorly to a Magnus
plate which doesn't help his case yeah
Hans might have cheated in that game but
we'll never know I
I think day by day
the evidence is slowly starting to show
more and more that
he's cheated it like like how Magnus
said more than he said and more recently
it's undeniable like right a lot of the
statistics are there the problem is
you can't prove you're not cheating
yeah unless you strip naked like that
site offered him a million bucks to like
everything about the which site of a
headline that said Hans Neiman bucks
and where I struggle to comprehend is
how on Earth he could pull it off
and
like I'm a guilty that my brain goes to
guilt first and resent yeah resentment
remorse guilt that kind of that Trio